le système de retraite français un
acquis social depuis 1945 auquel il est
bien difficile de s'attaquer
[Applaudissements]
premier exemple en 1991 inquiet du
vieillissement croissant de la
population et de ses conséquences sur
l'équilibré du système de retraites le
premier ministre michel rocard avait des
idées dont celle ci afin de préserver le
système par répartition dans lequel les
actifs paient pour les retraites des
inactifs il faut selon michel rocard
progressivement adapter le système
première variable que l'on peut modifier
le temps de cotisation c'est le passage
des 37 ans et demi à 40 ans de
cotisation l'âge de départ à la retraite
était alors fixée à 60 ans la
proposition du premier ministre ne
faisait donc pas vraiment l'unanimité
auprès des syndicats il est question
dangereusement de remettre en cause
l'accès à la retraite à 60 ans
l'idée de michel rocard aboutira avec
son successeur edouard balladur en 1993
mais uniquement pour le secteur privé
alors deux ans plus tard en 1995 le
premier ministre alain juppé y pense
aussi pour la fonction publique et les
régimes spéciaux est il normal que les
gens cotisent 40 ans les eaux 37 ans et
demi
réponse immédiate des syndicats de
fonctionnaires mobilisés dans toute la
france on a subi un contrat quand on est
entré dans la fonction publique pour
travailler 37 ans et demi vient aucune
raison que gouvernement nous trop pas
changé un contrat maintenant la forte
mobilisation de 1995 fera finalement
renoncé le gouvernement les huit ans
plus tard en 2003 autre tentative du
premier ministre jean pierre raffarin sa
nouvelle réforme des retraites vise
encore une fois le secteur public elle
est alors défendu par son ministre des
affaires sociales françois fillon alors
on augmentera progressivement la durée
de cotisation pour passer à 41 ans en
2012 là encore l'idée a du mal à passer
auprès des syndicats de fonctionnaires
malgré les contestations le texte de
jean pierre raffarin et beauté quatre
ans plus tard en 2007 la nouvelle
réforme du président sarkozy prévoyait
aussi un allongement de la durée de
cotisation mais pour les régimes
spéciaux les syndicats de cheminots
monté au créneau maintenant on va me
dire alors que je connais depuis tout le
monde me dire qu'il voulait le plus loin
or il n'en est pas question
cette fois ci le gouvernement ne cédera
pas mais accorder des compensations aux
chemine en 2010 nouvelle réforme des
retraites sous la présidence sarkozy et
le manifestations étaient encore massive
[Applaudissements]
cette année-là l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite est définitivement repoussé
à 62 ans aujourd'hui le système de
retraite français est toujours un sujet
de crispation pour les deux finalistes à
l'élection présidentielle une réforme
semble inévitable
[Musique]